back now is Raymond Arroyo and also
joining us is Craig Shirley presidential
historian biographer Raymond I love that
story I have chills chills watching it I
get teared up watching it yeah what was
the big takeaway well the big takeaway
Laura is the ingenuity of the American
worker and the American entrepreneur
here on the ground in at home and that
unity of purpose they all had that they
were fighting the war at home on the
streets of New Orleans blacks whites
women underage boys were working around
the clock to build these landing crafts
and it's Churchill said two empires are
tied up in some GD things called landing
crafts and they were Craig surely it's
so great to have you on tonight I know
you've been here many times to Normandy
I want to read something that David
christened you rode in the New York
Times Magazine that really struck me on
my way over here from Paris tonight most
men in the first wave never stood a
chance
but Allied troops kept landing wave
after wave
it wasn't bombs artillery or tanks that
overwhelmed the Germans it was men many
of them boys really slogging up the
beaches and crawling over the corpses of
their friends that one the Allies a
toehold at the western edge of Europe I
got teared up I feel like I'm gonna
start bawling during the show because
every grave behind us represents a life
cut short and given for our freedom and
Craig you've written so much about this
over the years tell us what's going
through your mind tonight well I'm
thinking listening tonight Laura and
watching the last day or so is is that
the pages turning in history and the
book is closing on the last generation
so thank God that the ones who are alive
were there to celebrate this monumental
challenge you know our old friend Lynn
nob singer who was work for Ronald
Reagan for so many years was one of
those Rangers on one of those troop
transports and was on Normandy on June 6
1944 years later I was having lunch with
Lynn and I just had him to look down in
his hand and notice that his two fingers
on his left hand were gone and I always
thought he lost him in a power to
accident
and I asked I said what happened to your
left hand he said Nazi shrapnel he
climbed the cliffs and he put his hand
up and his in half his hand was was
blown away but he never he never bragged
about it he never talked about like most
the greatest generation they came back
and went back to work you know a lot of
them you know didn't like to talk about
it and until until recently but he told
me is that the seas were so so we're so
wavy and so uncontrollable that by the
time they got to the Normandy Beach they
were ankle-deep and puke from all the
other troops
yeah we think and we think we're talking
about this we're talking about this on
the way over tonight you know it's
pretty cold out here tonight it's maybe
40 degrees and you know it's you know
it's like live TV you're doing 20 my
things that we stopped when we say wait
a second
think about what was happening 75 years
ago at this hour in the dark they didn't
know where they were their compasses
half of them were broken they didn't
know what they were gonna come upon and
have Lee and Raymond have we gotten a
little soft here well as you know Craig
only a few of the men in those early
transports made it out of the transports
the dirty of this 36 men were killed
instantly because of the German
crossfire that they were encountering
hitting the beach so you know they
didn't call this bloody Normandy for
nothing go ahead Craig no I was just
gonna say that that think of the
logistics but planning the d-day
invasion you're moving the population of
a mid-sized city a hundred and fifty
thousand men and tanks and cargo and and
jeeps and medical supplies and food
supplies and guns and ammo and all the
other things the logistics that went
into the planning of the d-day invasion
are really staggering if you really
think about moving that 150,000 with all
those munitions and supplies then 22
miles across the open sea through choppy
waters to then land as Raymond said in
the murderous Nazi crossfire we played
this soundbite I think last night
everything's blurring into one day here
but of the Queen and what she said this
week about
shared sacrifice it's worth watching
again the anniversary of d-day reminds
us of all that our countries have
achieved together after the shared
sacrifices of the Second World War
Britain and the United States works with
other allies to build an assembly of
international institutions
Craig they said Trump would wreck the
international institutions NATO wouldn't
survive Trump and here he's in a few
hours he'll be here with other world
leaders to celebrate this alliance and
honor those who served and those who are
buried behind us yeah I think it's
speech tomorrow is going to be important
for him I think that's an understatement
if I was giving him advice Reagan spoke
so eloquently on the 40th anniversary
about the past and kind of bringing
closure to it Trump should almost be
symmetrical and talk about the future
the future of the Alliance the future of
the United States the future of the
Western alliance the future of freedom
opportunity and hope and challenges for
all the for all the people who are part
we were part of the original war against
the Axis powers but the expanded part of
the expanded countries as well I look to
the future Craig thank you so much